What's the background to an artwork like this?
Where does this painting by Picasso come from?
Could it have been expropriated by the Nazis?
Looted, stolen?
Every little detail on the back of the painting
is a clue.
To answer those questions, the Berggruen Museum
in Berlin has examined 135 artworks in its
possession.
The conclusion: none of the works were stolen.
We don't want any stolen or illegitimately
acquired goods in our collections.
Even if it's a major work.
If it happens, it must be returned.
So far the Prussian Cultural Heritage Foundation
in Berlin has returned a total of 350 artworks
- and that might just be the tip of the iceberg.
It's estimated the Nazis stole around 600,000
works of art, mostly from Jewish families.
And many of them have still not been returned
to their rightful owners.
... like some of the works found in 2012 among
a stash of 15 hundred pieces in the Munich
apartment of Cornelius Gurlitt, son of the
war-time art dealer Hildebrandt Gurlitt...
Pressure is growing on German lawmakers.
Many think the process of determining and
returning stolen artworks takes too long.
And opposition parties are demanding more
money be spent on restitution.
I'm not satisfied with the situation because
in this case, action really speaks louder
than words.
Action has to be taken.
And if the museums don't have the funds to
deal with this, then we the government have
to see to it that we come up with the funds.
Visitors to the Berggruen Museum appear to
be on the same page when it comes to stolen
art: Germany has to work much harder to track
down looted works.
The Gurlitt case really showed again how much
of a sorry state we're in where that is concerned.
I think much more work has to be done.
We have to get our house in order on this.
If we don't, there's this nasty feeling, and
it's something future generations will always
end up being confronted with.
For behind many an artwork, there still lies
a gruesome story of Nazi theft, expropriation
and injustice.